I have noticed sure now we're talking
about the things that money does do and
it doesn't do it certainly doesn't make
you happy if you're miserable and you
get money you'll be unbelievably
miserable you know if you got a temper
and you get money you will have an
unbelievable temper you know you just be
the jerk of jerks it makes you more of
what you already are I'll tell you
something that does it it does seem to
lower drama you know when I was broke it
was like I was so broke I couldn't
breathe you know your life looks like a
country song you know what I'm talking
about
like everything is falling apart the car
is broken the kids are broken the
marriage is broken you know your health
is broken it seems like everything is
like keep the dog out of the street
he'll get hit you know I mean it's like
everything is going wrong I remember
being so broke I couldn't pay attention
and it was like everything was a drama
putting brakes on the car was a drama a
kid getting a call was a drama because
it all had money connected to it we were
so broke we couldn't do the money we
couldn't breathe and it was like there
was constant drama - drama - Drumm
emergency - emergency - emergency -
emergency you know when you get a little
bit of money piled up and you get out of
debt
it takes a lot bigger event to qualify
as drama it's just you know it's not a
big deal you can go there you can do
this I mean there's there's certainly
things that money can't
I'm not saying money buys happiness I'm
nothing at all I'm just saying that the
car brakes are no longer a drama car
tires blowing out or no longer a drama
they're you know that this I want to go
on a vacation is no longer a drama I
want to change jobs there's no longer a
drama because you've got this pad
between you and all the crap that life
shovels towards you and it changes
things it's worth it it's worth the
price you pay to get on a budget it's
worth the price you pay to get out of
debt it's worth the price you pay to say
no now so you can say yes later it's
worth the price you pay to sit down with
your spouse and
an agreement about what you're gonna do
with your money it's worth it when you
see the smile on the end of another
person's face because you were able to
give and do something to change the
drama in their life it's worth it it's
worth it it's worth the price you pay to
live like no one else so that later you
can live and give like no one else
that's what we want you to do we want
you to win with money we want you to be
able to serve God and take care of your
family and be a quality citizen and I
can promise you the more the money piles
up the less drama there will be in your
life except for those personality quirks
that will be magnified because you can
count on it
whatever's going on is gonna be
magnified when you get money this is the
Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or 27
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income or $500,000 in
economy
you